Chris Gore, Founder/Owner of
FilmThreat/Author/Filmmaker: If I could cancel
or wipe away or if I could just do the
snap that Thanos did I would get rid of
every franchise reboot post probably '92.
Film Courage:
If you were the head of a movie studio what
five movies would you green light right now?
Chris: If I was head of a movie studio and
I could green light five movies I don't know
if it's cheating but I would green light three
movies which would be to redo the sequel trilogy
to Star Wars. I mean maybe that could count as
one but I feel it was such a dissatisfying end to
I guess what was intended to be a nine film
saga although who knows when you're watching
this maybe they'll do 12 films there'll
be another star wars trilogy but I would I
would green like that because that's a safe bet
and we would we would do it right this time um
the other thing I would do is probably
probably Confederacy Of Dunces [1980 - Author John
Kennedy Toole] I think is a is a classic book that
you know a a lot of people have you know there
have been false starts to getting that made that
book turned into a movie another one would be the
Chuck Palahniuk book Survivor [2010] which is a
probably you know you know one of his greatest
books has such an incredible scene set during the
super bowl that if it's ever committed a film will
be incredible I don't really know how you could
really make survey Survivor would have to be done
almost in the way of fight club you know just like
with a big budget and just like not care what
people think but it's it's about a guy telling
his story into the flight recorder of a plane
where he's allowed he's taken his plane hostage
he's this spiritual guru who has had been in
trouble with the law who now has commandeered
a plane you know and gotten everyone off the plane
so he is literally telling his life story into the
flight recorder and it's what he's saying into
the flight recorder that's the story being told
brilliant it's it's a book that I
will read every couple years just to
just to remind myself that this is what can happen
in in writing it's amazing so I would I would
green like chuck green light Chuck Palahniuk
Survivor which is famously where the the the
phrase “Suicide Girls” came from that that name
is you know the website was
named after a line in that book
is it that those type it's sort of a gossip yeah
it's sort of like oh those Suicide Girls and the
founders of the Suicide Girls website took you
know that line that inspired like oh we're going
to start a website based on that so that would
be one that I would do I you know I'd like to see
I don't know that a studio needs to do this I
would like to see a documentary about Marcia
Lucas. Marcia Lucas had such a profound impact
on on filmmaking in the 70s you know she was
just respected by everyone from Francis Ford
Coppola to Martin Scorsese to her husband George
Lucas there would not be a George Lucas if not
for Marsha Lucas there's never been a deep dive
I believe documentary about her speaking today
about you know I you can almost see there's like
Hollywood before Marcia Lucas and after Marcia
Lucas the impact that she had there's a there's a
rare and i've never seen it but i've read articles
about a rare rough cut of the first assembly of
star wars black and white you know taken from
you know the dailies they cut it together and
it's just like and it's an unwatchable film it's
terrible the original star wars I mean there's
like inappropriate humor which kind of reared
its head again in episode one the phantom menace
but you can see the the choices that Marcia
cut things out there are things where just a
few frames are cut and it changes the dynamic of
a character as seen in the cantina bar at most
before you know Luke Skywalker and Obi-Wan
Kenobi meet with Han Solo and Chewbacca Han
Solo's sitting with this attractive woman and just
sitting with her and she gets up and walks away
Marcia Lucas cut some frames she's not there
she's not even in the movie she saved that film
in the editing many of the special effects in the
original star wars the reason they're so impactful
is because they're not on screen for very long
so at the time that that came out I mean it was
it was so fast paced and a lot of the effects
objectively didn't work but because they were
on screen for so brief a moment it worked so I'd
love to see a documentary about Marcia Lucas that
really really details her contribution to film
not just star wars but you know how she was so
widely re respected you know by all the greatest
directors of the 70s you know and then after
her parting ways with George you know she was
basically ostracized I mean she was you know
working with her was she was just out of Hollywood
at that point so that one is a huge shame
I’m trying to think of others there's just
so many I would like to see the
comic book the dark knight returns by
frank miller that four-issue series you know
Zack Snyder was inspired by that when he made
batman v superman the thing that made the
dark knight returns so compelling was that it
it had all this history in it it would be great to
see that comic book turned and turned into a film
another one and maybe someone from
marvel is is if someone from marvel
watches this or listening listens to this
this is a comic book that no one knows about
I bring up every once in a while it's a
comic book called Strikeforce: Morituri
and it's about a group of people that have
superpowers they the that it's in a far future
of of the world where aliens invade and they're
slaughtering humans and the humans are losing
so there's a program that's developed to give
people superpowers there's only one catch you
only live for about a year so you don't know
what kind of superpower you're going to get
you don't know how you're going
to help in this battle against
these aliens these invading aliens but
you only get to live for a year so you're
you're putting your life on the line and sometimes
you don't even live that long so it focuses on the
second group of heroes that have gone through this
process it's it's a series that that Marvel did
back in the 80’s never forgot that story that it
was really impactful filled with pathos and drama
a whole group of I mean it was you know it just
a whole diverse group of characters all this
like the the the world's at stake but it wouldn't
really fit into the marvel universe at all it's
you know because it's just sort of the
separate universe but I'd love to see that
I guess if i'm a Hollywood executive i'm green
lighting big budget you know franchise films
so maybe the Marcia Lucas documentary wouldn't
necessarily fit into that all that well
but you know god there's just so many I'd
love to see made what would you cancel
well I would have canceled probably maybe
the last five years of franchise reboots
there has almost universally not been one
that's succeeded in a way where everyone
is like that was awesome I mean you know just a
quick example like for example Lord Of The Rings
the Lord Of The Rings trilogy not
the hobbit the Lord Of The Rings
we don't really talk about that that series
of movies so much the reason is there's no
debate there's no debate people who don't like
Lord Of The Rings I’m not a fantasy film fan
right and I wasn't a Lord Of The Rings fan
necessarily I remember the hobbit cartoon by
rankin bass back in the day which used wrote an
early form of rotoscoping which is interesting but
but I was not a fan of Lord Of The Rings per se
and that movie made me that series of movies made
me a fan you know it's incredible we don't really
debate about that because there's not that much
debate they're objectively amazing films if you're
a hardcore Tolkien fan yes there are nitpicks but
there's almost no debate about it but I don't know
that we'll ever stop debating the disappointment
that that was that star wars sequel trilogy I
feel like that is a debate that will just continue
I just wonder will Hollywood learn the lessons I
would want to go back in almost every franchise
that was rebooted Ghostbusters Terminator
Dark Fate you know there's so many you know
did we need more fast and the furious movies you
know I I don't know it it seems to me that these
that these franchise reboots I mean in some
cases there has too much time has elapsed
between you know they want to do another film and
and whatnot it's just because the branding exists
right there's that recognition you know like when
they you know like when they name a movie after a
familiar song right like that's sort of a laziness
on the part of on the part of Hollywood but yeah I
would if I could cancel or wipe away or if I could
just do the snap that Thanos did I would get rid
of every franchise reboot post probably 92. what
about a star is born did you see the first one
yeah a star is born well that see but it's
such a different approach because there's
you know it's the music world has changed
it's about being invested in those characters
that I don't really think fits in that category
I think that star is born is just a classic story
that's just like okay it's this is familiar the
bottles from familiar we're gonna put like maybe a
slight different flavor you know I like those
they have those different flavors of Coke
like Vanilla, Cherry, Cherry Vanilla,
Orange Coke, Lime Coke they do make that
so it's familiar but with like a a twist and yeah
I mean that Star Is Born movie with Bradley Cooper
and Lady Gaga is pretty damn incredible you know
I really don't have much to say about that one
you know except good job Bradley Cooper as the
head of a movie studio what would be your mission
and what would it be called by the
way what would your studio oh well
yes it would be called Gore Film okay that
would be my movie studio and I would I mean look
you have to tell stories where it's an amazing
story without the superficial elements right
there has to be something to say about you know
our current climate we live in such divided times
I don't know why there are so few films about
that why are we so divided why is it that people
living in the same country who all want the same
things why are we so divided now and there are
so few films that are dedicated to that you know
I do see a lot of documentaries and generally
the documentary films of a political nature are
generally they're on the left or they're on the
right and it's it's really disappointing because
as the viewer I would like to be able to come to
my own conclusion rather to be led into one that
you determined before you started making the movie
so i'm surprised that when you look at
the kind of issues that films from the 70s
you know were taking on very challenging issues
I don't know why we're not doing that now so much
of Hollywood now is about dictating some sort
of predetermined message it's not entertaining
I don't mind if some of that is is woven
in but I do mind being told how to think
and I think it that if if I was head of
a studio I'd not be telling my audience
how to think and I would certainly be
listening to what the audience wants
and maybe giving them something they
didn't expect that I hope they really like
but certainly not pounding them over the head
with some sort of agenda you know I think I
think we're more alike than we are different
and I don't know why we're not reminded of that
so that would that would be my mission
and to tell original stories giving
opportunity to small indie filmmakers to
tell original stories taking some risks
not every science fiction movie needs to have over
the top spectacle with the fate of the universe
at stake when you look back at some of
the old star trek episodes there's so
few special effects shots right it's star
trek really delved into the realm of ideas
and I'd like to see science fiction come
back to dealing in the realm of big ideas
and you don't always need big spectacle or big
budgets to tell those stories so do you think
Hollywood can learn lessons from let's say art
house cinema or foreign films where there's a
subtlety there may still be a message but it's
it's letting it breathe it's letting the viewer
discover it whether they're going to agree with
it or not whereas maybe in western culture we're
beating them over the head it's so overt that
there's no hiding it that it's forced I i'm just
curious what yeah I think I think we've forgotten
you know Joseph Campbell and The Hero's Journey
you know I you know I guess so much of films today
seem like they kind of want to break that mold
there's a reason that mold works it's kind of
embedded in human DNA you know that kind of
around the fire storytelling is is universal and
that seems to seems to have been forgotten lately
in trying to break that mold i'm just
i'm just you know especially when we see
you know The Hero's Journey for so many female
lead characters I think a disservice is being done
to people who look up to those characters because
it's made to look easy people forget how much
failure there has been in some of the iconic
movie characters everyone from Luke Skywalker to
rocky people forget in the original Rocky film
Rocky loses he loses the fight now he gains
respect which is more of what that film is about
but he lost the fight in the original Raiders of
the Lost Ark Indiana Jones loses. He's tied up his
only logic is I’m going to close my eyes to not
to not get caught up in these evil spirits
that are coming out to murder everything right
he kind of loses I mean maybe he wins in the end
because he gets he gets the ark he doesn't really
get the ark because it's tucked away in a giant
warehouse but he loses there's something about
losing and this happens more in indie
films than it does in Hollywood movies
you know what happened in the Empire Strikes
back Luke lost he lost the fight he lost his hand
you have to I really feel like if it's not tied to
character I don't know how the events of that film
really can be meaningful if it's not tied to some
hero character journey that you're on where you
can because we all fail in life believe me we
all fail in life life is just I mean look it's
just learning from your failures right I mean
that's and i've made plenty of mistakes in my
personal and professional life that I’ve paid for
and I like to think I’m who I am today is better
that's that's just failures failure is how we
learn and I feel like by not imbuing that lesson
we're doing a disservice to young moviegoers
who might look up to these heroes it really is
it's kind of a disappointing time to see how
franchises are being you know twisted in a way
that I don't think serves the audience but
but there's something to be said for losing
characters that lose more often than they win
and what exactly you win I think Rocky probably
being the most obvious or best example of that
because then they just made Rocky II Sylvester
Stallone made Rocky II and the oh it's pretty
much the same movie I mean there's some little
fun differences in it but but it's the same movie
but he wins in that one he actually wins the fight
but it's kind of the same movie they just
revisit a lot of the same stuff in the film
but but he wins whatever but the fact that
rocky lost but he won he had a girlfriend
Adrian he'd want a girlfriend even though he's
kind of this simpleton right this sort of thug
but anyone respect it wasn't about winning
that fight it was about winning respect
and that was tied to him in his humanity and
his soul and his character and being that's why
they made so many rocky movies because that
character's so endearing you know and and we're
on that journey that constant constant failure
until the end and then he wins the fight but
but in the first one he lost and and almost no
one remembers that if you ask right now ask any
person you see like who won the fight in the first
Rocky and it was Rocky won the fight no he didn’t.
If
you were the head of a Hollywood movie studio
what 5 movies would you green light immediately?